цьогоріч уряд планує розпочати масштабну
реформу вищої освіти Про це повідомив
прем'єр-міністр України Денис шмигаль 5
січня Кабмін вже ухвалив два
розпорядження про об'єднання закладів
вищої освіти зокрема в Одесі та
Миколаєві із чим пов'язана така
оптимізація скільки закладів вищої
освіти планують закрити чи об'єднати про
це говоримо із заступником міністра
освіти і науки України Михайлом
винницьким вітаю вас Доброго дня Ну
давайте Так ви відразу розпочали з того
що ви говорили про дійсно є два
розпорядження які А ми прийняли це
першій розпорядження стосовно
модернізації нашої мережі а модернізація
мережі передбачає дійсно певні
приєднання слабших закладів До сильніших
закладів а певно зменшення кількості
закладів вищої освіти але насправді це
не є суть самої трансформації яка
запланована урядом на 24й рік і надалі і
насправді мова йде про деякі інші
законопроекти е в першу чергу мова йде
насправді про зміну систему фінансування
закладів вищої освіти і взагалі систему
бюджетного а фінансування освіти для
абітурієнтів мається на увазі що на
сьогоднішній момент у нас є система яка
базується на тому що людина або
бюджетник або контрактник і дуже часто
різниця між бюджетником і контрактником
це може бути Ну буквально там тисячна
бала при а за за при зовнішньому
незалежному оцінюванні справді мова йде
про те щоби а зробити систему грантів і
ця система грантів передбачає що для
найкращих результатів по ЗНО буде
оплачена повністю 100% їхня підготовка
але може бути грант який буде
перекривати наприклад 50% Чи 60 чи
70% вартості навчання і таким чином ми
можемо взяти ту частину державних коштів
які передбачені для вищої освіти і її
розподілити більші кількості студентів
на сьогоднішній день в нас 40% отримують
бюджетні кошти а 60% - це контрактники
наша ціль є зробити з точністю до
навпаки що 60 а то й більше відсотків
вступників будуть отримувати державні
кошти для здобуття вищої освіти можливо
що це не буде повна оплата Але тим не
менше Вони отримують державну підтримку
свого здобуття освіти і маленька частка
залишиться тих які все-таки будуть
стовідсотково оплачувати контрактом
бажання скоротити кількість закладів ви
освіти пов'язано із цим розподілом
фінансування Ні це насправді два
паралельні процеси ще є третій
паралельний процес який називається
збільшення суб'єктності студентів через
формування можливість формування
індивідуальних траєкторії А це все є Це
все є кажу елементи великої
трансформації яка зараз відбувається в
системі вищої освіти Ми маємо розуміти
що інфраструктура наша по вищій освіті в
багатьох випадках є нам перейшла ще з
радянських часів коли в Україні було
по-перше набагато більше вступників
кожного року навіть взяти 15 років тому
це вже далекий пострадянський період у
нас було приблизно 650 000 випускників
шкіл щороку Сьогодні Цього року в 23му
році у нас було 360 000 випускників шкіл
і очевидним є те що та мережа Яка
існувала 15 років тому на сьогоднішній
день не відповідає сьогоднішнім
сьогоднішнім пара
а Очевидно це питання не тільки у
випускниках шкіл це так само Питання в
тому що економіка сама по собі змінилася
ми поступово переходимо від
індустріальної економіки від планової
економіки до постиіндустріальної
економіки і подивіться на те які зараз є
професії які є Ну потрібні для для для
для майбутнього це професії дуже часто
Які Ну не ті самі які були для галузевих
закладів які існували скажімо собі а
20-30 років тому які сьогодніще дальше
існують але вони вже давно перестали
бути галузевими і насправді А ми на
сьогоднішний день формуємо власне мережу
більш класичних університетів
міжгалузених а між Якщо хочете таких
таких які можуть дійсно забезпечити
вибір студента е стосовно предметів
стосовно викладачів а це бо болісний
процес ми це дуже добре розуміємо бо
інфраструктура так чи інакше
скорочується але це питання насправді не
лише у війні хоча війна тут в даному
випадку нічого нам не допомогла але це
насправді в тому що нас з року в рік
скорочується кількість населення і це
знову ж таки не через міграційні процеси
чи так дальше просто демографія в нас
менше дітей менше дітей 17 років тому
родилося ніж в подібному періоді
наприклад 30 років тому Чи 40 років тому
коли ми будували ту інфраструктуру яку
ми сьогодні маємо А можна будь ласка на
прикладі закладів які вже оптимі вали в
Одесі та Миколаєві Як пройшла
оптимізація по-перше треба розуміти що
коли ми коли ми
проводимо злиття закладів або приєднання
закладів то обов'язково всі студенти
переходять
із ну скажемо так освітні програми
дальше продовжуються до до їх завершення
так що нічого не змінюється на рівні
освітніх програм які вже існують але
змінюється дещо для нових вступників так
що вже тепер з
з серпня-вересня місяця ми будемо бачити
що студенти вступають вже в об'єднаний
заклад Це перша річ яку треба сказати
друге що насправді ті галузеві заклади
які приєднані Ми залишаємо затримуємо в
тих закладах які вже тепер об'єднані
затримається
певний автономний інститут наприклад у
випадку з одеським одеським
університетом імені Мечнікова до якого
приєднаний Одеський екологічний
університет буде функціонувати
екологічний інститут як автономна
структура до якої До речі вона буде
підсилена так само одним з таких
екологічних науково-дослідних інститутів
який був у віданні Міністерства освіти і
тепер приєднаний також до закладу вищої
освіти Одеський національний університет
імені Мечнікова Так що ми посилюємо в
Цей спосіб університети А чи там де були
програми наприклад є економісти які
готувалися в Одеському екологічному і
економісти які готуються в мерчникова от
впродовж наступних півроку рік буде
певне об'єднання цих двох програм і
студенти побачуть Що наприклад можливо
деякі навчальні плани можуть дещо
змінитися а можливо деякі викладачі
поміняються але в принципі це все
націлене на те щоб покращити якість і
затримати ті унікальні речі які мали би
бути затримані на прикладі можна сказати
що отримують студенти в наступному році
в університеті Мечнікова більші
можливості вибору своїх предметів тому
що вони будуть мати більшу кількість
викладачів які будуть пропонувати
вибіркові курси і ці вибіркові
курсибільшать Якщо хочете меню цих
курсів які студенти можуть обирати
відповідно вони зможуть сформувати Краще
свою індивідуальну траєкторію навчан яку
кількість закладів вищої освіти
плануються яким чином
об'єднати я немає кількісного якогось
таргета дещо в інтернеті там почали
писати про якісь там цифри на
сьогоднішній момент це місто за містом
ми дивимося де є можливості для
модернізації ми обов'язково не називаємо
це оптимізацією тому що оптимізацією це
не є тут питання не в тому щоби
закривати задля закриття чи там задля
того щоби якісь кошти заощаджувати і так
дальше мова йде про модернізацію мережі
а кожне таке об'єднання кожне таке
приєднання так само передбачає певні
інвестиції з в науково-дослідне
обладнання науково-навчальне обладнання
лабораторне обладнання А в нас є
програма світового банку яка передбачає
що при кожному такому об'єднанні
університет отримує між мільйона і і млн
доларів обладнання для того щоби
продовжити і покращити свою
інфраструктуру Отже мова іде дійсно про
модернізацію мережі Скільки буде таких
закладів Я думаю що життя покаже зараз я
цифр точно не буду називати якщо не
говорити про цифри а просто для
розуміння які заклади можуть
розглядатися для
модернізації ну дивіться в нас є е
достатньо велика кількість галузевих
закладів які на сьогоднішній день
перестали були бути фактично галузевими
от власне Одеський екологічний
університет це це це принцип це це
приклад такого де насправді там екології
залишилося дуже-дуже мало а в силу того
що Е Там вже і і і юридичний і
економічний різні маркетинги і так
дальше програми розпочалися це вже
перестало бути галузеве і відповідно
коли ми говоримо про те що це вже
міжгалузеве то в даному випадку ми маємо
розуміти що при укрупненні при
збільшенні закладу міжгалузевість
означає кращу якість Але ми не можемо
бути міжгалузеві і маленькі Отже в
даному випадку мова де про укрупнення
тих закладів які мають галузеву історію
і її втратили і в результаті дуже часто
втратили так само і на якості при такому
укрупненні наша ціль завжди є покращення
якості вищої освіти Ми намагаємося
максимально об'єднувати там де є
можливості створювати кращі кампуси
мається на увазі там де є фізична
близькість де ми можемо говорити про те
що студенти будуть дальше
використовувати приміщення які е Які є
ее ну призначені для освітнього процесу
щоб вони далі продовжувалися для
освітнього процесу цей процес не процес
об'єднання модернізації немає нічого
спільного і в даному випадку абсолютно
не передбачає будь-якої приватизації
землі чи приватизації приміщень і так
дальше приміщення залишаються за
призначенням такими які використовуються
в освітній процес я вам дякую за
роз'яснення нагадаю що це був заступник
міністра освіти і науки України Михайло
Винницький